all right welcome to this live stream
with our back-to-back live streams we
are now going to be looking at spatial
statistics
for
version 13 of orphan language and we've
already looked at a bunch of things here
so remind me where we have to look next
did we get um
roger and so on here
uh
not yet
well
okay can gosha can you remind us where
we got to last time
we can you can open the guide page uh
called special prediction
we discussed some changes for the names
which are not reflected in this notebook
that you're showing but
i put them in the guide page
okay
what is it called spatial social
prediction
we don't seem to know about it
a special prediction there no space
okay
hello okay
so special okay so this this is the
obsoleted stuff this stuff so the yes
the green highlights were the older
names and the ones below which are the
new suggestions
from last meeting
okay spatial estimate
special trend model okay so this was we
had not fully gone through that right no
right
okay so variogram function
variogram function is now an option to
spatial estimate
okay which tells you which model of this
local dependence to choose
okay spatial noise variance
that's another option correct that's a
yes that's another option
is it obvious that that's assumed rather
than deduced
yes no i mean it's obvious given that
you know how it works but is it obvious
from the name
oh um
maybe not actually
um
because i would have expected that to
compute a spatial noise variance
i mean it can estimate it from the data
as well
all the worse
because then there will be a function
that you could imagine using that's
called spatial noise variance that
estimates it from the data
i mean
[Music]
it's
i mean
i'm not sure it would make
a lot of sense to estimate it in by
itself
like it makes sense to estimate
the name is confusing i mean
where do we have other names where we
are assuming
certain kind of i mean it's like a
precision or something where we're
assuming working precision or something
right that's a case where we're assuming
something
well okay where do we assume something
about data
what's an option where we assume
something about data
uh
oh option
it should
let's see so
i mean if we called it like spatial
noise level or something or spatial
noise
if you call it spatial noise
nobody thinks that's something you can
compute because it's not a definite
number
yeah it's okay
it will be okay by me
either the level is almost better
well especially as there's the automatic
limit spatial noise
i agree special noise level seems
spatial noise level seems fine to me
okay
all right next next up what's next
spatial estimator function
i think we talked about that last time
right right so you see it changed from
predictor function to estimator function
fine
okay now we didn't talk about very
this spatial trend model and so on right
right
i mean we did but we didn't come up with
a different
name
so this is
this gives a actually we did talk about
it we had various names sort of this is
a model structure or a model family
this is what i'm saying it it did you
that the thing that you give here is
either polynomial
degree n total degree
yeah right okay
or
constant or or free form which we agreed
would not
have the x and y's here
that's in order to have formulas instead
of functions
i mean you have the thing is that even
with functions you have to have the x
and y's whether you hold them hash signs
or x and y's
you know
if it's a pure function well i mean if
we called it spatial trend model
function
we're pretty clear what it is
but can you yeah i guess we could and we
could just have then say that you can
estimate it
you can either give a function it's your
responsibility to do your fitting you
know take your business elsewhere
basically right but this is friendly
this is you know this thing of giving up
you know automatically estimating a
polynomial total degree polynomial model
because otherwise
sure but i mean the spatial and we've
got plenty of cases where function arrow
integer does something automatic
right
family of global trends to fit to data
spatial trend function
sure
why is it called a trend
basically just the thing you're fitting
to the data yeah
just thinking i don't know the history
of trend but i can imagine
that it came from the univariate case
where you'd see a sort of a trend in
data
okay but okay if this was called spatial
fitting function or something
spatial fit function
what is the function actually doing what
does the function actually represent
it wants to get the data to be
uh zero
zero mean
that that's the goal for what it should
achieve if it's how you relate to the
trending function
it is a d trending function it is a d
trending stage
but we know what's this
it's not there we don't have it
because it's but also don't i'd also
don't want to make this function that we
have a multi-step function because now
spatial predict can no longer be single
step
okay so this is the function that you
apply
what does it actually do you've got this
you've got this random hillside
and it's got all sorts of flapping
around and then you apply this function
to it and what does it do
okay
so so this function is supposed to model
that hillside when you add them together
you get the data that you came in with
so in the conversely you subtract
that function and you get the local
variations
you know what i'm saying if you add
those two together you get the actual
data
we're going to add which two together
now the thing you global trend
the global trend and the local variation
and noise where's the local variation
that's that's explained elsewhere you
know you you
what's is there an option for that
spatial this is the option that's the
variogram model that's the local
variation that's the variogram model and
then the noise the spatial
noise level that we that we agreed so
that's the part the point is that that
the the global trend can overwhelm
anything that you compute on on the
level of local variation so you want to
remove any global trend that you know or
you notice so then you actually you know
this this variogram method again tell me
what
something plus something plus something
gives you
so you can have you can have just the
global trend which is just kind of a
special function which is the left
picture it's a nice smooth function then
you add some local variations and then
you have your you know your surface that
you actually want to model
in this so what are we doing we try to
remove the global trend so this is the
the trending that happens with the
special trend model and then focus on
this local variations in noise to
you know to fit the variogram model into
this so then we can have the the special
estimator function
and then when you when you
when you look at the special estimator
function you know the output would tell
you whether there was a you know linear
trend or a constant
um and such so when you then query the
values this global trend will be taken
into the consideration to give you the
appropriate estimate for the space for
this so let me see if i understand so
then what we've got is
we've got
spatial noise level
which is what we're assuming
about how much wiggling around there is
is that correct
wiggling comes from two things yes one
one is
uh you know kind of inherent that
um
actually look at that last the the last
three point plots there those three
and
if you assume that your data
the value at each point is measured
absolutely exactly with no error in it
whatsoever
yes then you would want your surface to
go through the points to interpolate
if
you don't think that you've measured
your values a hundred percent correctly
that means you can't trust the values
100
then you then you want to sort of weigh
the uncertainty
in those values
with
how much things are varying in the local
dependence model
so the more noise you think that are in
the values the less you should trust the
individual values and trust more
the the the values around you
basically
and that's what that's dependent on
that's in that dependence model
okay so let's just understand what are
the different pieces here
so
okay what is bind variagram is that
something completely different yes it's
it's still a variogram but it's
basically a and it's also called
empirical or sample diagram and it's
it's unfortunately not a valid variogram
but it can tell you something about data
so wait a minute is it like variogram
function which is it going in or is it
coming out
no
neither it's a it's a it's a kind of a
data estimation of the model so this is
your you know this is this gives you the
idea what your model possibly can be and
that's what we what we then feed to the
certain family of models
it's a little bit like histogram list
you know in what it spits out
well how like it is it
you know
pretty much
the same thing
in the sense that not how it computes
things but how it
reports things
so why isn't this called variogram list
or something wait a minute why do we
return weighted data
because each each pair so each pair
which is the distance and the mean var
the mean of the variance is for this
distance
is also weighted by the number of pairs
that you have in each bin so that also
gives you the information on the on the
amount of of like reliability how many
pairs you had to obtain this value
and so if you if you if you if you look
at
at this point value plot that we see
here it shows you that the the most
pairs you have in the middle in the
middle section of this
bin variogram
and then at the end so for the very
large distances and what the small
distances you have fewer pairs so
your
your whatever your estimate there it's
not so solid as what you get in the
middle
um
okay
but here's to what you can read off in
that diagram stephen
if this thing if this thing goes to
infinity like this last plot does
then there's a good chance that
basically you have a trend that you
haven't taken care of
okay okay so then you didn't correctly
de-trend the data if you like or there
is a trend that needs to be taken care
of
okay
we have a suggestion here about looking
at some
this is a um
an explorer
that is you zoom
yeah i opened these things
it's the blockchain wi-fi thingy thingy
what does it do
as you zoom in
that's kind of interesting goes to
geohistogram type thing although here
it's just showing
that the thing is present right
what is this form
this is a this is a blockchain connected
this is tokenizing wi-fi access
basically oh so has nothing to do with
helium at all
uh
well i don't think so
who knows
wifi okay wi-fi
um
okay
but anyway so i mean
i don't know what this is
that's interesting that when when you
zoom in
to the points
i mean that's a geo histogram basically
except a geohistogram which doesn't show
how many things there are in a given
area it's just going to a particular
scale right
mildly interesting okay anyway it'd also
be the privacy issues that dude they
will not give exactly a wi-fi position
well yes
right
there um
okay
so i'm sorry uh this is too complicated
for me go through this again so hold on
so very grand model
what the heck is this this is a setting
what is this for
a model okay so last time we talked
about about it a bit and so variogram
model as we decided it's going to be the
output to the estimated variogram model
but on itself it's also a container of a
model so what you get out of it is the
variogram model and you can see the
alighted form and it's it's it gives you
the the type of the variogram and you
know a little illustration okay so
estimate the varigram model returns a
variogram correct
so that's that's kind of our
that was your that was your idea from
last time right okay so then what is the
thing that whose value is set to be
variogram model
that's variogram
functioning the the spatial estimates
okay fine fine
okay verogram model
well i i would not say a function
representing a variogram i would say
a symbolic representation of a variogram
model yes yes that's the best
yes but it behaves like a function in it
i don't care
you mean that you mean that you can
apply it to things yes
if you have yeah
i think we should say a symbolic
representation of a very ground model
what what what happens when you apply it
if you apply it to three what does it do
it should give you the value at three
does it apply to points or r values no
it should should only kind of give you
something reasonable for positive uh
reals so scalars positive scalars
scalars to points in in rn okay so is
variagram function is the setting for
variable ground function
a variogram model or something different
so for variogram function you can you
can you can input the var the variogram
model so variogram model can be
given to variogram function i mean to
specialize in
functions as a setting yes okay so exam
function arrow variagram model of blah
yes
okay
but you don't i mean normally you want
the automation to kick in to find it for
you you don't want to which is then
going to basically call estimated
variogram model and just figure out yes
so you can give you can give a string
and it's going to estimate the
parameters for example
for the given type okay
an estuarinated variogram model returns
a verigram model but a bind variogram
does not returns
just the data
yes
it's not intended it cannot be
actually here's the thing
gosha that should be possible input to
estimated variogram yes it is
okay great yes fine
um
good so so on its own it can be used as
input to estimate a a proper bariogram
model
that can be used for spatial prediction
but can also be looked at and understand
something about your data
as i said when that goes to infinity
when that looks like it's not um
saturating at the that highest level
that it saturates at is called the sill
it tells you how
how much variance that's fine but but
the the result from build very i mean
the thing that's really bothersome to me
is that the name variogram
is like a histogram and it suggests an
image which these are not none of these
are
so the analog of built of histogram
is bin lists right
yeah
no no isn't there histogram list it's
history
is slightly different yeah okay
but so could we add lists to the end of
this
could you explain is it if we just said
variogram
lists that would be wrong
it would not be necessarily wrong but
that would not be precise
enough if we want to have different
methods to compute
sample variogram
possibly in the future
list is what you are proposing
i would i would think that would explain
what's happening that we are doing
binning and that's the method that we're
computing the variograms right now
been very groundless okay we got one
more to go
um
the trend the trend the trender the
detrender
right
okay so
spatial noise level
and then this detrending
is again i have to remind myself
where is it
special
okay
okay we've got spatial noise level
special trap
why isn't it just spatial trend function
it can be that's a perfectly fine thing
okay that seems like what it should be
okay
all right what else do we have to figure
out here i think that concludes it
okay
i have just one question if we are at
this because uh looking back as the
estimated variogram model versus
variogram model feet
you have a suggested alternate name you
mean yeah i mean we could i don't know
if we discussed that but but in the way
i i thought about it after our last
meeting and we have like time series
model feat that retained returns time
series model
and so
you know like maybe this is also um
more into the fitting than necessarily
the estimation methods which would you
know maybe connotate with maximum
likelihood method of moments what did
this you know what the fitting with the
distributions is you know what i would
expect if you do fit is to
uh supply a bunch of properties to give
you quality of fits and other data as
well
don't we have a whole estimated
you know we have a whole estimated
family so to speak we do yes isn't this
doing something like that isn't this
basically returning
your the best guess of a history of a
variogram model
it does it does it's a part it's a it's
gives you the best parameters
the the parameter values for given well
but it actually returns the variogram
model
yes yes i think the right name is is
because our fit functions
somewhat annoyingly in some cases don't
actually return the fitted function they
return a bunch of other craft as well
right
i mean
that was that was in version seven was
the first time we'd introduced you know
composite data structures like that
um
but they do behave what gets returned
actually do behave like a function even
if you don't see the formula
right
um
okay
uh
let's see any further questions on this
so so
i think we understand how this is
working um
i mean if i wanted to get just naive
question okay
so i've got
let's say i've got satellite imagery
and i want to how do i feed that into
let's say i want to find out the density
of lakes in a given area what would i do
for fun yeah so
i think if you want a density estimate
that's what we shipped in 12-2 that's
like
you know you basically kind of have
point data if you like
i mean it's it's a crude way okay but it
is you know you have to see the lake as
a as a point
but that will take
points to densities
and we have a whole family of such
density estimators there
so that we provide it
okay um
um what
okay so what is this so so image
processing you need something that sort
of gives you the points the locations of
where they are the things that you okay
so what you've got here
this one yeah this is this is like you
have a bunch of values kind of like list
plot 3d gets a bunch of values
you know
at 2d locations
you know and the question is what is the
surface that drapes over it
okay
okay
you know because you've so for example
in the lakes example if i wanted to plot
the lake density as a function of
position in minnesota or something
yeah what would i you did density
so here's what's slightly confusing if
you have a bunch of discrete data you
can talk about densities of them right
if you have but but the density is
itself in fact a continuous surface over
the space
yes so that density is in fact the field
yes
okay
so
um
if yet if you had values that said what
the density is that the different things
this one can fill in the missing data if
you like
okay so one of them is the is the
spatial point process where it's just
saying there is a lake here so let's say
that i also knew the size of the lake or
let's say i knew that the
average number of some kind of fish in
each lake
yeah so i've got lakes and they've got
you know goldfish whatever carp whatever
it is
right
and so then what i'm trying to do what
you're what you're saying is that
spatial estimate would give me
the cop as a function of position
throughout minnesota yes
and that's kind of how it started you
know like this mr krieger
was looking for gold deposits
and so what happened is that you would
drill a hole and establish what the
level of deposit was at that hole
right right then you would drill another
hole
and then you want to interpolate the
values in between right because because
you have an assumption that there is a
process that spewed gold out in the
early history of the of the planet yeah
and
that
the you know
you are basically sampling that scalar
field of gold density exactly sampling
it at points yes
yes you know
the only pity of all of this
is that that story
of estimating a scalar field for example
is a more general story than the geo
story
mean
these things that we're building here
are very
geo-oriented
no
it works it doesn't have to be geo
i mean they're spatial oriented the
spatial oriented but then also going
back
i mean it's taking us a lot of effort to
make it work for jail i mean seriously
okay fair enough i mean
what does it mean
why is it called spatial
because
yeah
well because looking at the spatial
distances between the the data points so
we look at the
the the the space distance
i see so that the argument is it's
living euclid in space but i mean
everything is right but i mean all of
our things list density plot assumes
you're living in euclidean space
you're right
yes but it's also assuming that you have
connections and so the the underlying
model for this is that the things that
are closer are correlated so the values
will be similar
and for the things that smarter
plot assumes the same thing
right but the way that you that you do
your interpolation it's not necessarily
linear you know you don't go with the
line but you have these different models
that come from the variogram
computations but so why is it the case
let's imagine that we do list density
plot
okay why are we not using all this
technology to make better less density
parts we will
it's coming stephen and that's the
discussion we're going to have probably
for thirteen one
yes
but thank you thank you thank you
stephen good tier what well you just
said what i tried to say before earlier
okay but but hold on a second what i'm
concerned about is when we say
special statistics what what is it that
you wouldn't think of doing i mean
and and a lot of people have actually
asked for this because the quality of
of of sort of list density when you
don't have dense data is not
um so great i mean but but this is the
same story as the as the story forever
of should you spline your curves when
you don't have adequate data yeah it is
but this one gives you
you know so so
this one gives you
we talked about these two knobs right
the the the local variation in noise
this gives you a way to trade them off
it gives you sort of
the right
norms basically i understand but if
we're doing all of this and we're going
to make list density plot be able to
essentially spline its data i mean not
in actuality but something like that
right the generalization of splining its
data
we i mean i guess we have interpolation
order
for list plot which does the same kind
of thing yeah so we're going to have to
probably come up with a new if you have
a brilliant idea there i'm i would okay
so does does list density plot have an
interpolation order right now yes
which means what
which means uh
it it actually is using splines
interpolating splines
okay
but then this is
a a whole different way but i think that
there's some technical limitation i
can't remember now exactly
i think it doesn't you work for
irregular data or some such i recall
it works only for regular i see that i
think well but okay but so fine i would
i would not totally surprised but
basically what this is doing
is
it is providing
okay
i mean there's a good example
similar to interpolation go ahead we're
going to say
there's a good example the ozone example
right like with the big gaps that maybe
can help you see
how it kind of works
where do you have that example this is
and also steven going back to your lake
example you can imagine that you want to
map the bottom of the lake and you
sample the the depth
you know at some points of the lake and
so that could serve you to create a
surface the bottom surface for the lake
yeah this is such a weird business i
mean this is such a frigging weird
business
because this is just like splines and
curves it might be right or it might be
nonsense
and the question of what's true depends
on the underlying thing that is
generating this i mean ozone
may be such that it obeys the fluid
equations or something or
maybe i don't know maybe it's maybe
hydrodynamics more or something but you
know but you're right stephen so that's
a question of models you know when you
use models to fill in
yeah because you're just garbage well it
can be yes
you know right so but but but even
interpolation itself is a model yeah
it's a model yeah
i mean the only question is how
insidious the model filling in yeah the
missing data imputation ends up being
yes exactly
right
i mean of course we humans do it you
know the standard optical illusion where
you put up
you know you
look at something with one eye and you
have a big blot in the place where your
optic nerve comes out of your retina
and you just see the graph paper
continue that's us doing interpolation
right which we do all the time and where
the fact is in that particular case you
got it totally wrong because there was
actually a big blop there blob there
um
okay well interesting stuff um
i mean i think what you're saying here
i'm just trying to understand his is the
thing that i'm trying to understand
this is a general way of interpreting
scalar fields given point data
right
yeah
and my question is
i mean
there's nothing special about us about a
scalar field
it's just values it's not it's no more
spatial than list density plot is
spatial
am i making sense
are you going metaphysical on me now
well not terribly well the the spatial
maybe in the sense that you have to find
metric you have a distance way of
measuring distances between your data
i see as opposed to list density
i see but list density plot doesn't
really care
fair enough okay
spatial
okay okay i get it it's nice
there's a comment here
yeah there's a comment about auto
completions yeah we're working on
fancier
bigger stronger auto completion
not for this meeting and there's also
completions are great to everybody isn't
it i think there's one of the automation
things that we built that's just great
and we want more of it we want more code
yeah we want more voter systems more of
it everywhere right
you know we'll get into the situations
like when you type in messenger or
something like that on your phone where
it auto-completes slightly wrong and
it's sometimes embarrassing it's like oh
no didn't mean that yeah yeah right well
but but the thing that we're really
going to is code assistance where you
have kind of spell checking
uh squiggly lines under code that we
think is
sort of heuristically likely to be wrong
and so on and that's working for great
that will be i know that's what the
whole big effort roger i know i see it
from a distance i'm just not in the
trenches with it so yes well it's it's a
lot of ways to go but it's getting there
and i mean hopefully eventually the type
analyzer will be able to be hooked into
that as well which will give us a bunch
of other information
all right we should wrap up here okay
thanks guys good stuff and uh thanks to
folks on the live stream and see you
another time okay bye for now